- Super Bowl of course
coming up this week, Anthony.
- Who cares?
- But first headline.
- Who cares about
the Super Bowl?
- Is from the Real Bowl,
it's called the Pro Bowl.
It went down.
- The only bowl I care about
I eat my cereal with my hands,
'cause the only
bowl I care about
(laughter)
is the Pro Bowl.
I just throw dog
food on the floor.
(laughter)
'Cause I'm all
about the Pro Bowl.
- Lot of the football
world this week.
- I don't own a toilet.
(female laughter)
- Just shits on the ground.
In the corner.
- There's only one
bowl I care about and
it's the Pro Bowl.
It's what the NFL season
is geared towards,
it's what it's all about.
Everything is just
all about the Pro Bowl
and you know what, that
wasn't always the case.
Back when it was in Hawaii
after the Super Bowl,
it wasn't that big of deal,
now that it's in between
the end of the playoffs
and the Super Bowl
and it's in Orlando,
the best of America,
now it's number one.
- There is some
concern this week
that the Pro Bowl
was so exciting,
people are really not going
to be into the Super Bowl
anymore.
- It was, it was.
I mean, everyone talking
about the one play.
You know and we're
not gonna get into it.
We're not gonna get
into the xs and os
but it was a
beautifully coached game
and the players
showed a real passion.
I think that's what people
are gonna be talking about,
even during the Super
Bowl, is how much passion.
I mean, those guys left it
all out there on the field.
- All on the field.
You often talk about oooh
there's not as much pass rush
in the Pro Bowl,
not this Pro Bowl.
- Oh my God, this Pro Bowl.
It was almost like the
offense was pass rushing.
Do you know what I mean?
They were so into it
and just the stats,
I mean, unbelievable.
It was like, the thing
about the NBA All Star Game,
how much fun that is and
how much offense there is
and then you think like
the NHL All Star Game.
Imagine if the
basketball players
had to put on ice skates.
That's what this
Pro Bowl was like.
- And what a tough week
really for Stephen A. Smith
who's famous for
being a Cowboys hater
and Jason Garrett,
especially is a guy,
the coach of the Cowboys
that he picks on quite a bit.
After watching what
Jason Garrett did
on Sunday night in
Orlando, case closed.
- Jason Garrett saved his job,
probably saved a lot of
jobs during that Pro Bowl
and, you know, I don't have
the final score in front of me
but it was amazing.
(laughter)
I just love the Pro
Bowl more than anything.
I wish they could
play it twice a year.
And the skills competition,
are you kiddin' me?
All those skills,
every one of them.
There wasn't a single
skill that I was like
that's more luck or a
gift, it was all skills.
- What throws.
- What throws what catches.
- What catches.
- Oh my god.
- Some diving plays.
- They really put the pro
in Pro Bowl this year.
- John Coughlin was a two time
United States pairs champion
in figure skating, Anthony,
died by suicide last week
in Kansas City, Missouri.
He had recently been suspended
from U.S. figure skating.
He was 33 years old.
- So this had nothing to do with
the Kansas City losing
to the Patriots,
this was just, do
you know why he?
- It happened shortly
thereafter, yes.
- And what was he suspended for?
- Officially there's
not a reason,
but there has been
some reporting that
there were sexual
assault allegations
that he was suffering from.
- Yes, I love, listen suicide
is an important topic,
a very serious topic, but
when someone's just like
"I screwed up so bad that
I'm pulling the plug."
I think it's great.
I always think you're just like
I don't wanna go
through a trial,
you know what I mean?
I don't wanna have to
explain this to my mom.
I'm just gonna go.
I always think that's great.
'Cause at first it was
like, "Oh what happened?
This is some horrible tragedy."
This guy was like a
champion and worked with,
you know, trained people.
I'm sure kids were
involved in some way
but you're just like
"Oh, you guys want me to
get punished for this?
You know what, I
got plans of my own
and I'm just gonna
see you all later.
See you on the other side."
I find that delightful.
- I was wondering
where you could find
the lightness in
this story going in,
but I do find myself
laughing at your ridiculous
statements.
- Like I believe,
when people are like, "Oh this
person's a child molester,
why didn't they just
kill themselves?"
I'm like, yeah, I understand
that, I agree with that.
But when you kill
yourself afterwards
it's just kinda like "I'm
not gonna let you guys win.
Yeah, I sexually
assaulted all these people
and I'm not gonna face any
punishment for it, I'm out.
I didn't even like
ice skating anyway."
- Let's move on to
a lighter subject.
Let's talk about a nurse
in the Phoenix area
who was arrested this week after
it was found out he raped
and impregnated a woman
in a vegetative state.
- Yep, a couple weeks
ago you probably heard
about the story, there
was a woman in a coma
and she got Kill Bill'd.
She was in a coma and all
of a sudden she's pregnant
and they're like "Oh,
uh, we're in trouble.
The hospital is in
trouble, we're gonna
get to the bottom of this."
And you knew they were
gonna solve it right away
because all you do, is you
look for the happiest nurse.
(laughter)
There's only so many people
going in and out of that room,
which one's the happiest?
He did it.
I'm surprised this guy
didn't pull a figure skater
and just be like,
"I'm not gonna.
I don't wanna have to
answer these questions.
I don't have to look someone
in the eye over this."
But I'm glad they did get him.
Although, like, okay.
- It was at one
of those facilities, like
an assisted care facility.
- Sure, you're in a coma,
I'm a big fan of like, if
I'm in a coma, pull the plug,
I don't wanna live like this.
Even if they're like, there's
some rough possibility
in 20 years they'll
figure it out.
If I'm asleep for
more than 24 hours,
I'm out, you know what I mean?
- Who's in charge right now?
Do you have it
written down that?
- I do not have a living will,
I've just told enough
people that I hope
that they would be like,
"He wouldn't want this."
But when I do do a
will, I will say,
you know, pull the
plug immediately.
- Get on that.
- Yeah.
But if I was in a
coma, you know what,
do what you want.
(laughter)
You know what I mean,
maybe, I'm not gonna say
that it's a good thing,
but I'm not worried about it.
It's like necrophilia.
Who's the victim, you know?
- Well maybe the
families of the body.
- If you see it, yeah, sure,
otherwise, you have no idea.
But necrophilia's
better than having sex
with someone in a coma.
- Like in what way?
- Because the
one person's dead and
one person is alive.
But, uh.
- What?
- It's less of a victim thing,
do you know what I mean?
So you guys are telling
me if you were in a coma.
Maybe I'll do this,
I'll have a living will,
but if I am just in a
coma for a little while,
do what you want to me.
- That's part of the will.
- Or would you guys
be like, "Don't touch me."
- I mean.
- Would you let
someone have sex with you
if you were in a coma.
- Probably not, I
mean I'd hope not.
That woman's impregnated now.
- Yeah, that's true.
I mean, that's a bummer.
- If you're gonna have sex
with someone in a coma,
use protection.
- That's a bummer for that.
- It finally occurs
saying "Well, that's
true, that's a bummer."
- Yeah, I didn't
think about the kid
who comes out of it.
I just assumed the pregnancy
wouldn't go that far.
- No, she just had the baby.
- She just had the baby?
- Is she still in a coma?
- Yeah.
- What?
- I just like that when
- The baby's doing well.
- When they saw the bump
they were just like, "Oh, jeez.
Oh we're getting a talking to.
There's gonna be a meeting
at corporate over this."
You can't do it, nurses.
This is why male
nurses get a bad rap.
'Cause whenever a nurse
kills a bunch of patients,
it's always a female nurse
but whenever a nurse
knocks up someone in a coma
it's always a dude.
Why is that?
(intense rock music)